okay tonight I will be on the drunken
peasants show this entire thing if you
haven't heard of the drunken peasants
look them up online we had a live caller
ID say like four to six weeks ago Pat
yes and they said something like David
would you be willing to appear on a show
like the drunken peasants or an
illiberal show and i responded sure i'm
willing to appear anywhere if it makes
sense if i'm invited regardless of
political views and then a bunch of
people after that call started tweeting
to us saying hey uh you should be on
drunken peasants and people tweeting to
the drunken peasants saying you should
have david pakman on and then Pat had
the idea to actually get in touch with
them and they were receptive to having
me on and that's the long and short of
it right I will be on now yet it's gonna
be great to watch I know I'm gonna be
tuning in because you seem to be a
little bit more eloquently spoken and
deliberately spoken whereas they don't
care who they offend and are just blunt
about things well entertaining I am NOT
one of these individuals who is
completely concerned with optics if
you've been watching this show you know
that and I know that generally speaking
we're going to have a many points of
agreement but there will also be point
of disagreement it will be I i believe
it starts at nine p.m. eastern and I'm
not totally sure if I go on at nine
fifteen or exactly what it is the best
way for people to watch live is YouTube
is that correct that is correct it may
be the only way I'm looking forward to
it I know Rachel your titillated by this
right yes I'm definitely tuning in okay
cool